Let's build up some objects that have a lot of similarities so
that we can see how prototype chains might help us.
On the right here, I'll show a picture of the objects that we're creating as we
go and the relationships that they developed.
Here we have a property lookup on the gold object.
Let's consider every step of what happens when we do a property lookup for
the key a in this object.
The interpreter kicks off an investigation as to whether or
not the gold object has the property we're looking for.
Upon inspecting the object, the interpreter could tell that there
is a pair available in this object that has the key a.
The value that's associated with that pair is 1.
And so the result of this lookup expression is going to be 1.
In this case, our logging system would log value 1 out to the screen somewhere.
My code assumes that there's some function called Log that already exists.
In most environments, you would call it console.log.
But, let's take a look at what happens when we ask for
a property that we know the object doesn't have.
First, that property lookup arrives at the object.
And then the interpreter acknowledges the failure by providing undefined in
response to this attempted lookup for z.
And, so the lookup for z on the gold object,
results in undefined which is what ultimately gets logged to the screen.